[Music]
and here old man would lean in close and
whisper how can you tell if the man is
wearing the Beast what the Beast is
wearing the man what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 Theory video I
planned on releasing a different video
today but an idea just came to me about
the night king that made me drop
everything I was doing so I could
immediately work on this video I think I
came up with a different twist for how
Game of Thrones could end as far as I
know I haven't heard anyone else discuss
this possibility yet at least not in any
of the videos that I have seen what I am
about to talk about is just a theory
right now it's not something that I'm
necessarily predicting to happen but I
think it is interesting enough to talk
about and see what all of you have to
say about it so far I still need to
flush out the details a bit but I wanted
to get some of my initial thoughts out
there before I get into what I think
could possibly happen let me set the
stage first let's start with some of the
things that we do know about the night
king we were first introduced to the
night King in season 4 episode 4
Craster was having his sons left in the
woods as a sacrifice to the gods and in
this episode we learned exactly what
that meant a white Walker came and took
the baby then he carried the baby to the
lands of always winter he placed the
baby on an altar made of ice
then the night king revealed himself in
some of his powers by placing a finger
on the baby's cheek he was able to turn
the baby into a white Walker then in
season 5 episode 8 we got another
glimpse of just how powerful the night
king is while John was at hardhome they
came under attack by thousands of whites
John and his small group of companions
were able to make it out of there live
along with a small force of wildlings
but the majority of the wobbling
encampment was slaughtered as John was
leaving the night King revealed himself
again and he also revealed one of his
greatest strengths as a show of power
the night king lifted his arms and all
of the fallen wildlings opened their
eyes and they started to stand back up
the wildlings eyes were now blue just
like the night kings and the
white walkers I think most of us assume
someone was controlling all of the
whites but when the night King brought
all of the wildlings back to life right
in front of our eyes it pretty much
confirmed it for me
it seems as if the night King is warding
all of the whites at the same time and
there is more evidence of this in later
episodes in season 6 episode 5 we
learned a great deal about the night
King and possibly where he is getting
his powers from while bran was at the
three-eyed Ravens cave he entered the
weirwood net by himself when he did this
he came upon a small force of whites led
by the night king and a few of his white
Walker lieutenants as bran approached
the whites it became obvious that the
whites were motionless almost as if they
were asleep but when he got to the back
of their formation he saw the night King
along with the three white walkers the
night King knew that bran was there and
when he turned his head to look at Bryan
all of the whites had turned around
simultaneously as if they moved when the
night King moved but the night King gave
no commands nor did he motion for them
to move so it seems as if they were all
being controlled by his mind very
similar to warding but the most
important part of this episode was when
we got to see the night King's creation
the night King was created by the
children of the forest after they had
plunged a dragonglass blade into his
chest as the dragonglass pierced his
heart it turned his eyes blue so I think
it's safe to say the night King was the
first white Walker to have blue eyes and
it could help explain why all the other
White Walkers and whites eyes are blue
too because they are all under control
of their master the night king it's very
similar to what happens when we see
Bryan warg into an animal or even Hodor
Bran's eyes roll back in his head and
turn white then the eyes turn white with
whatever he is working into when we saw
the night Kings creation it made perfect
sense why he would have the same type of
powers as well only the night King is
much more powerful than brain as right
now the night King was created by the
chosen of the forest and the children of
the forest get their powers from the old
gods one of their main power sources is
the weirwood trees and in this episode
we learned the night king can tap into
that power source as well which is why
the night king was waiting for bran when
he entered into the weirwood net the
children gave the night king all these
powers when they created him and bran
has these
same powers - he just hasn't learned how
to harness them yet we have seen brand
Morgan to animals and even people just
like the night king but we haven't seen
bran be able to control an entire army
yet but Bryan also has a power that we
haven't seen the night king use yet
either and this is where we get into the
main part of this theory there is one
awesome power that wargs or skinchangers
have not only can they control animals
but they can also live second knives
through these animals if they are about
to die they can't enter the mind of
something else and live on through that
there is a great example of this in this
show during season 3 episode 9 when John
is traveling with the wildlings they
have a ward with them named Orel while
John is with them they order him to kill
this old man to prove that he is one of
them but John refuses to do it in a
fight breaks out during this fight John
manages to shove his sword into orals
chest but he is able to cheat death with
his working abilities and right before
he dies he wargs into the eagle and he
uses the Eagle to attack John John might
have stopped his heart in his original
body but now he is able to live on
through his eagle but stronger wargs may
have the ability to take this a step
further in the books there is a
character that goes by the name of very
mere six skins he is a very powerful
warg that is able to control six animals
at the same time after Stannis smashes
the wildlings right outside the wall
Faramir flees and he ends up getting
stabbed by a boy when he tried to steal
a cloak off of the boy's dead mother he
was mortally wounded by this and he knew
he was on the verge of death instead of
just working into another animal so he
can still keep his consciousness he
decided he wanted to take this a step
further by living a second life through
a person instead of an animal right
before his body gives out he attempted
to warg into a woman named thistle but
when he does this the woman has a
terrible reaction as if a virus just
entered her body when she feels him
inside of her she starts screaming and
clawing out her eyes she ends up biting
off her own tongue and verum ear can
taste the blood so he leaves her body
and enters one of his wolves instead he
tried to live a second life in another
human but he wasn't able to but perhaps
a more powerful warg
bran stark and the night king may have
this ability since they both seem to be
the most powerful characters that seem
to be tapping into the same power source
we have seen the night King into the
mind of animals and people but they have
all been dead what I want to propose is
what if the night King enters the mind
of a living person and this is the big
twist at the end of the series Jon Snow
and his companions are on a mission to
kill the night king and they just might
get their wish but what if the night
King enters the mind of something or
someone else right before his body gives
out it's not exactly clear if the night
king possesses this power or not but
there may have been another clue in
season 7 episode 5 when brain sends the
Ravens beyond the wall when brand went
spying on the night king he immediately
sensed that bran was there when the
night king looked up at the Ravens they
almost exploded and brains snapped out
of them it seemed as if the night king
forced him out of those birds and it was
another show of the night king strength
his mental abilities are still
overpowering brains abilities and this
is messing with Brian's head bran knows
the night king affected his working and
he can also affect what happens inside
of the weirwood net there was another
interesting scene during season 7 that
may have been a clue that the night king
won't be stopped if you just kill his
body in season 7 episode 6 we learned
that when you kill a white Walker you
also kill everything the white Walker
raised or was controlling John killed
the white Walker and all of his whites
dropped later in the episode
beric Dondarrion suggests that if you
kill the night king then you should be
able to stop his entire army that's
another
kill him
he turned them all
you don't this time why did John say
that does that mean the night king or
his army won't be stopped even if you
take out the night king I have seen a
theory that says bran stark will have to
enter the mind of the night king in
order for John to be able to kill him
but I wanted to flip that theory on its
head I believe it's entirely possible
that the night king may leave his body
Rita's John or someone else attempts to
deliver the fatal blow they might think
the night king and his army was defeated
but if the night King enters the mind of
something else right before he dies in
the night King will live on just like
all other wars have the ability to do
but let me know what you think about
this idea do you believe it has some
potential to happen or am I crazy I am
anxious to see what some of you have to
say about this one
put all your thoughts questions or
opinions down below I want to thank
everyone for checking out today's video
I really appreciate that and I also want
to thank my patreon supporters I am
still making your Q&A video I just had
to push it back an extra day but keep
your eyes open for that one as well
have a great day everyone I'll see you
in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]